Nous sommes devant une section de la lettre de Paul aux Galates qui traite surtout ce qu'on appelle la sanctification.
Nous savons que le thème central de la lettre c'est la justification par la foi,
sauf que dans la conception de l'apôtre Paul, pour plus qu'il soit surtout en train d'exploiter un terme qui a plutôt des justices,
en termes forensiques, la justification c'est un terme qui fait référence à la cour, à une cour des jugements,
où une personne est déclarée devant les juges comme en étant juste.
Cette déclaration, elle peut faire référence à la nature de sa justice, une personne qui était possiblement injustement accusée,
ce qui n'est pas le cas pour nous tous, pour la race humaine.
Nous avons été justement accusés comme injustes, mais on a pu trouver cette déclaration de la part du juge.
Vous êtes justifiés, c'est-à-dire vous avez été déclarés justes.
Et donc Paul va expliquer quelle est la base de cette justification pour les chrétiens.
Ce n'est pas une justice propre, nous aurions pu conquérir par notre observation de la loi,
mais c'est surtout d'avoir placé notre foi, notre confiance,
d'avoir embrassé comme représentant légal devant les tribunaux de Dieu,
celui qui Dieu lui-même a envoyé pour vivre la vie parfaite à notre place,
et par là pour voir la justice qui nous manquons,
mais c'est lui aussi qui a souffert à la croix la punition juste
de nos péchés et nos transgressions.
La double dette, obéissance parfaite d'un côté,
et punition méritée, c'est l'écrit ce qui pourvoit.
Dans la plupart de la lettre, Paul insiste pour expliquer
qu'aucune personne ne sera jamais déclarée juste devant Dieu
si c'est néqué par la justice l'un autre,
un seul, Christ, les fils des dieux, venu en chair.
Ça, c'est la grande première portion de la lettre.
Et ensuite, il passe à traiter une implication inséparable
de cette œuvre des justifications.
Ceux qui, par la foi, ont embrassé Christ comme représentant,
et donc par la foi ont été déclarés justes de manière juste,
ce sont ceux qui non seulement se sont unis à Christ
et à son œuvre par une foi extérieure,
par cette œuvre faite d'une fois pour toutes dans l'histoire,
et ce sont ceux qui ont été unis à Christ
de manière radicale par les Saint-Esprits,
par une nouvelle naissance,
qui les a fait naître de nouveau.
Donc ils n'ont seulement été déclarés justes
et adoptés légalement par Dieu,
mais ils ont été faits justes,
ils ont été rendus justes,
ils ont été faits enfants des dieux
par une transformation intérieure.
Donc Paul insiste que la compréhension
plus large et totale de la justification
n'est pas qu'une question légale,
c'est une question d'une œuvre complète.
Et la réalité, c'est que lorsqu'au moment de la conversion,
quelqu'un place sa foi en Christ,
elle est en train de prendre conscience aussi
qu'elle a été intérieurement, spirituellement,
greffée en Christ,
à la vie du Christ.
Et bien sûr que les restes de la chair,
donc cette justification par rapport à laquelle
on a été rendus justes,
on a été déjà totalement déclarés justes.
Mais le fait qu'on a été rendus justes,
c'est pas une œuvre encore complète.
On a été rendus radicalement justes
car on a été greffés à Christ,
son esprit habitant, non ?
Et l'œuvre et les ministères principales
de Saint-Esprit,
c'est de nous faire progresser
en sanctification.
Donc quand Paul évoque
dans les V.C. 22
les fruits de l'esprit,
il est plutôt en train d'aborder
cet autre aspect de la foi.
Pas les débuts de la foi,
mais la maintenance de la foi,
la continuité de la foi,
les développements de la foi.
Et donc le but de l'apôtre Paul ici,
c'est de rappeler
ce qui est un privilège exclusif des chrétiens.
ils ont la capacité
de manifester les fruits de l'esprit.
Ils sont en train de rappeler
que ces personnes-là,
qui ont vécu une espèce
de déviation de la vraie foi,
particulièrement dans leur comportement,
ceux qui ont réchouté quelque part
dans certains péchés,
qui peuvent aller dans la direction
essentielle,
les deux endroits.
D'un côté, les péchés du légalisme.
Pensez qu'après avoir été converti
par la foi seule,
je dois maintenir mon salut.
Je dois m'assurer
que je ne vais pas perdre mon salut
car je suis en train
de performer
par des rites
et des œuvres religieuses.
Comme si la maintenance
dans la foi dépendait
de notre obéissance,
de notre observation religieuse.
Et l'autre côté du péché,
c'est ceux qui sont plutôt convaincus
du fait que Christ a tout payé.
Ils se sont menés
dans une direction
de se dire
« Donc, quand Jésus a tout payé déjà,
je vais me livrer au péché. »
Donc, ces deux comportements,
attention,
un,
qui cherche l'œuvre parfaite
et complète du Christ
comme une excuse
pour tomber dans le péché,
sont plutôt en train
de manifester
une mauvaise compréhension
de la vraie foi,
sont en train d'agir
contrairement
à leur nouvelle nature
s'ils sont nés de nouveau
et donc,
ils sont plutôt en train
de manifester
des évidences du fait
qu'ils ne sont possiblement
pas convertis.
si une personne
dit
« Jésus a tout payé,
je peux me plonger
dans le péché »,
c'est plutôt
une manifestation
qui devrait nous faire douter
de l'authenticité
de son salut.
Et de l'autre côté,
ceux qui se disent
« C'est par mes efforts,
par mon observation religieuse
que je vais maintenir
mon statut
d'enfant devant Dieu »
ils n'ont rien compris non plus.
car
ceux qui ont passé
d'esclaves
à enfants,
la condition d'enfants
ne change jamais.
Donc la grande question
de l'apôtre Paul
quand on est en train
de considérer
la permanence
dans la foi,
la sanctification,
la progression de la foi,
ce n'est pas une question
conditionnelle
par rapport à ce
que nous pourrions faire,
mais c'est une question
d'observation,
d'évidence
d'une nouvelle naissance.
Donc là,
il est en train
de parler du fruit
de l'esprit
dans un contexte
où il cherche
à redresser
les comportements
des Galates.
Et Paul,
il est convaincu
que lorsqu'il avait
prêché à cette église,
les Saint-Esprits
a scellé
la conversion
de ces personnes
en faisant habitation
dans leur vie
et eux qui n'avaient
aucun arrière-plan
religieux juif
ont manifesté
des changements
de vie
tellement incroyables
où leur vie
était évidemment
reconnue
la nouvelle vie
comme une vie
progressivement
et évidemment
plus similaire
à la vie du Christ.
Chaque fois plus différent
de leur culture,
de leur génération
et chaque fois
plus similaire
particulièrement
à Christ
dans son caractère
par rapport
à la manière
dont ils s'aimaient,
dont ils étaient
patients les uns
vers les autres,
par rapport
à la manière
dont ils étaient
fidèles au vrai évangile,
par rapport
à la manière
dont ils ont passé
d'une vie
des débauches
à une vie
des tempérances
et ce que Paul
est en train
de faire ici
c'est de rappeler
quelle vie
ils avaient
avant leur conversion
quand il présente
les œuvres
de la chair
verset 19,
19 et 20,
et dit
des telles choses,
ceux qui commettent
des telles choses
n'hériteront point
les rames de Dieu.
C'est-à-dire
héritier,
c'est la définition
d'enfant,
ce n'est pas
la définition
de ceux
qui pourraient
conquérir
les droits
d'enfant.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
Et donc
ce qu'il est en train
de faire
pour corriger
les galates,
les toutes mauvaises
influences
sous lesquelles
ils étaient
et des possibles
péchés graves
qu'ils avaient
récommis,
c'est de rappeler
quelle est
leur vraie nature,
leur nouvelle nature.
Il n'est pas
en train
de faire
des coups de fouet,
des menaces
terrifiantes
comme quoi
ils allaient
perdre leur salut.
Il est plutôt
en train
de faire
un rappel.
Rappelez-vous
de ce qui vous êtes
depuis votre conversion
en Christ.
Rappelez-vous
de quelle influence
est prédominante
chez vous,
donc les Saint-Esprit
qui est prédominant
chez les chrétiens.
Rappelez-vous
de quelle est
votre volonté
la plus profonde,
celle qui est
la seule capable
de vous satisfaire
vraiment,
c'est-à-dire
faire la volonté
des dieux,
c'est sanctifier
et donc
la sanctification
selon la présentation
de l'apôtre Paul,
c'est une conséquence
naturelle
de la vraie conversion,
c'est la volonté,
donc c'est une
sanctification volontaire
de la part du chrétien,
c'est un fruit,
attention,
organique
et spirituel.
si nous sommes nés
de nouveau
et le Saint-Esprit
habitant nous,
inévitablement
notre volonté
va dans la direction
du Saint-Esprit
et inévitablement
nous manifesterons
progressivement
le Saint-Esprit.
Et même si
dans un moment
d'oscillation
dans la foi,
nous pouvons
nous dévier,
moins manifester
les fruits,
c'est intéressant
si une évidence
des vraies conversions,
c'est que
lorsque les chrétiens
sont exposés
à une exhortation,
à une discipline,
à une correction,
ils ne chercheraient pas
à s'excuser,
à se victimer,
ils chercheraient plutôt
à accueillir
la correction
pour pouvoir
à nouveau,
attention,
manifester
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Donc ce n'est pas
pour pouvoir
à nouveau
chercher
une expérience
radicale
des conversions,
des transformations
pour produire
les fruits de l'Esprit,
c'est de se rappeler
que le Saint-Esprit
est en lui
avec toutes les puissances
nécessaires
pour manifester
tout simplement
les fruits
en tant qu'enfant de Dieu.
Ce n'est pas pour chercher
à redevenir
l'enfant de Dieu,
ce n'est pas pour revenir
au début de la course
comme l'apôtre Paul dit,
c'est de se révéler,
se rélever
dès là où on est tombé
et de revenir en vie
des manifestations
du fruit.
Vous êtes avec moi ?
C'est ça l'objectif
de Paul ici
lorsqu'il rappelle
aux Galates
ce qui sont
les œuvres de la chair
qui marquaient leur vie
dans le passé.
Cette différence
à la fin du verset 21,
il dit
ces personnes
n'hériteront pas
les règles de Dieu
mais si vous êtes
et comme vous êtes
nés de l'Esprit
et c'est 22,
les fruits
de l'Esprit
c'est l'amour,
la joie,
la patience,
la bonté,
la bénéglité,
la fidélité,
la douceur,
la tempérance,
la loi
n'est pas contre ces choses.
Donc ici nous ne sommes
pas devant
des conditions,
nous sommes devant
une exhortation
à se redresser,
à manifester
les fruits
de l'Esprit.
Voilà pourquoi
le verset 16
c'est un impératif.
Attention,
il n'est pas
en train de dire ici
allez faire des campagnes
et des prières
jusqu'à ce que
ces péchés
qui sont devenus
votre péché d'habitude
aujourd'hui
soient disparus
de votre vie
par un miracle
de Saint-Esprit.
Et Saint-Esprit
il peut les faire
de cette manière
par un réveil personnel.
La prière
est un des moyens
par lesquels
nous allons chercher
à manifester
les fruits de l'Esprit.
Ok ?
Par contre,
ici,
c'est plutôt un impératif.
Pour ceux
en qui les Saint-Esprits
habitent déjà,
il y a déjà
la capacité
d'échanger de vie
et de manifester
les fruits.
Si nous sommes
redevenus
à une condition
où nous sommes
tellement mêlés
par un péché,
si c'est très difficile
de surmonter,
c'est car,
chapitre 6 va nous dire ça,
on s'est permis
d'aller trop loin.
On a agi
tellement
à contre-naturialité.
On a plutôt
cultivé
les œuvres
de la chair.
Donc,
attention,
une branche
qui était morte
et qui est greffée
à Christ
a encore
les restes
de la chair
qui essaie
de nous pousser
envers les péchés,
mais nous avons
une volonté nouvelle
prédominante
envers la volonté
du Saint-Esprit.
Et si nous sommes
greffés à Christ,
cette vie
prédominante du Christ,
cette présence
du Saint-Esprit
sera celle
qui va prévaloir
contre
les restes
de la chair
qui est déjà crucifiée,
qui est en train
de mourir
selon les passages.
Et donc,
les influences
du Saint-Esprit,
elles sont en train
de se manifester
de manière permanente,
prédominante en nous,
et les restes
de la chair
ne peuvent pas résister
à ces développements
spirituels.
Donc,
c'est un redressement
et la question principale
pour nous,
c'est de nous rappeler
que les fruits de l'Esprit
est donc une évidence,
ok,
ce n'est pas une condition,
c'est une évidence
nécessaire
et c'est une évidence
suffisante
car aucun nom chrétien
n'arrive à vivre
ce qui signifie
les fruits de l'Esprit.
C'est suffisant
et nécessaire
pour identifier
un vrai héritier.
Donc,
si nous sommes
en train
de chercher
à nous assurer
de notre foi,
il faut qu'on soit sûr
que nous avons
cette capacité
de manifester
les fruits
selon
l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit.
Les fruits de l'Esprit
sont essentiellement
une union
tellement vitale
à Christ
qui non seulement
produit
une connaissance
expérimentale
du Christ,
le Saint-Esprit
révèle Christ à nous.
quand on pense
à ses vertus
amour,
joie,
paix,
patience,
bonté,
elles sont sublimément
connues
et retrouvées
en Christ,
surtout par l'Évangile.
Donc,
c'est une connaissance
expérimentale
du Christ
et de l'Évangile
qui va engendrer
en nous
par cette union
avec Christ
la possibilité
que le Christ
lui-même
soit manifesté
non seulement
à nous
mais à travers
nous.
donc les fruits
l'Esprit
c'est révéler
Christ
en nous
former
Christ
en nous
et donc
il produit
également
la vie
du Christ
dans nos membres
depuis
l'être
intérieur.
C'est la réalité
du chrétien
et ça devrait
corriger
beaucoup
des mauvaises
compréhensions
dès nos jours
par rapport
à la
scientification
qui parfois
vont trop
exagérer
un travail
unilatéral
du Saint-Esprit
les personnes
sont toujours
dans la dépendance
qui par des baguettes
magiques
ou des miracles
ou des campagnes
les choses changent
dans nos vies
et qui oublient
la responsabilité
que nous avons
pour cultiver
cette transformation
pour manifester.
Certains
vont exagérer
aussi
l'emphase
sur la puissance
des restes
de la chair
et vont donner
aux chrétiens
l'excuse
pour se dire
c'est à cause
de la manière
dont j'ai été élevé
ou c'est à cause
de ma culture
ou
voilà
c'est une maladie
je suis addictique
de cette pratique
etc.
Pornographie
c'est pas quoi
et la réalité
c'est que
selon la perspective
publique
les oeuvres de la chair
sont appelées
péchés
et pas maladies
et les chrétiens
ont toujours
de son côté
de leur côté
la présence
de tout puissant
troisième personne
de la trinité
Saint-Esprit
qui pourvoit toujours
non seulement
la manière
d'échapper
à la tentation
mais tout ce dont
on a besoin
de persévérer
et progresser
dans la sanctification
donc c'est plutôt
une question
des résolutions
des responsabilités
des diligences
et donc
cette vérité
pour nous
c'est que
les fruits
de l'esprit
est l'évidence
nécessaire
et suffisante
pour tout
vrai chrétien
vrai héritier
des dieux
et on a posé
cette question
qui est la question
centrale pour nous
selon ces passages
comment maximiser
la manifestation
de ces fruits
si on est dans une période
en fructifère
comment nous redresser
si on est déjà
dans une position
plutôt favorable
comment agrandir
la manifestation
de ces fruits
comment plus fructifier
et donc
on a deux grandes réponses
à cette question
la première
c'est
nous devons connaître
la nature
et les fonctionnements
généraux
de cette fructification
et la deuxième
c'est
on doit connaître
chacune des facettes
particulières
du fruit de l'esprit
les fruits de l'esprit
c'est dans les sanguliers
mais
plusieurs facettes
sont présentées
amour
joie
paix
patience
bonté
etc
et donc
il faut être conscient
de bien comprendre
quelle est la signification
exacte
de cet amour
cette signification
pleine
spirituelle
liée à l'évangile
de cette joie
paix
ce que nous ferons
plus tard
par la suite
mais pour l'instant
pour qu'on puisse
bien comprendre
de quelle manière
ces fruits à cultiver
les saints esprits
exercent son influence
sur les chrétiens
de quelle manière
nous pourrons maximiser
ces fruits
il faut comprendre
de quelle nature
est ces fruits
nous avons déjà considéré
plusieurs aspects
on a considéré
que les fruits de l'esprit
sont organiques
donc à nouveau
c'est quelque chose
qui découle
naturellement
de la nouvelle nature
par cette union
au saint esprit
en nous
donc c'est les saints esprits
qui produisent
naturellement
ces fruits
c'est notre nouvelle nature
qui produit naturellement
ces fruits
c'est aussi
spirituel
c'est à dire
les fruits
c'est les fruits
de l'esprit
donc les personnes
ne peuvent pas
produire ces choses
d'elles-mêmes
les non-chrétiens
ne peuvent pas
produire
les types d'amour
qui est mentionné ici
ce n'est pas
n'importe quel type d'amour
c'est un amour
qui est l'amour
que Dieu a révélé
à nous
a manifesté
surtout dans l'évangile
et qui doit être
reproduit
c'est un type d'amour
qui aucun non-chrétien
n'arrive pas à produire
la même chose
par rapport à la patience
et toutes les autres
facettes
de ses fruits
il est spirituel
il est aussi
indivisible
donc là
on est plutôt
en train de considérer
la manifestation
des plusieurs facettes
inséparables
qui doivent toujours
se manifester
toutes
en même temps
c'est plutôt
la manifestation
du Christ
en nous
c'est plutôt
une personne
qui est ici
mentionnée
par les facettes
de ses fruits
c'est plutôt
un caractère spirituel
tout comme
les béatitudes
donc la réalité
ici
c'est indivisible
c'est plutôt
l'intégrité
ou l'intégralité
d'un caractère
qui se manifeste
il est aussi
permanent
donc
comme les saints esprits
dans toute la lait des Galates
nous est présenté
comme
les sceaux suprêmes
de la nouvelle alliance
donc le fait
que Christ
a fait
tout ce dont
était nécessaire
à faire
pour pouvoir
à la pentecôte
déverser son esprit
dans tous
les vrais chrétiens
tous les vrais
chrétiens
sont
habitation
de saint esprit
et le saint esprit
est appelé
comme les gages
de notre héritage
il est appelé
les prémices
c'est à dire
c'est une manière
des dieux
de sceller
et confirmer
d'une fois
pour toutes
et pour toujours
que cette sémence
qui ne peut pas
flertir
est responsable
non seulement
pour engendrer
la foi en nous
mais pour maintenir
la foi
en la conduisant
par son ministère
central
saint esprit
il n'est pas plus
saint que dieu
ou que les fils
mais pourquoi
il est appelé saint esprit
car son ministère
principal
c'est de le sanctifier
ce n'est pas
pour plus
que ça fasse partie
aussi
de son oeuvre
distribuer
les dons
mais c'est surtout
nous sanctifier
les fruits
comme a dit
Lloyd Johnson
les dons
même Satan
peut
faire semblant
peut produire
de manière
artificielle
par contre
les fruits
personne ne peut
faire les contrefaçons
c'est le saint esprit
qui produit
et donc ici
c'est important
il est présenté
comme celui
qui fait une oeuvre
permanente
celui qui
opère en nous
les vouloir
et les faire
c'est lui
qui nous garde
cette assurance
qui ne peut pas confondre
qui ne peut pas
flertir
cette assurance
vivante en nous
et donc
il est permanent
il nous assure
que ça sera impossible
qu'un vrai chrétien
se perde pour toujours
il peut traverser
des moments de déviation
mais le saint esprit
va les corriger
va les redresser
plus tôt
plus tard
il reviendra
à manifester les fruits
mais le fait
qu'il soit permanent
n'annule pas
l'effet
qu'il soit aussi
cultivable
et c'est cet équilibre là
qui est très important
à saisir
surtout dans nos jours
car certains vont
chercher à s'opposer
avec une très mauvaise
compréhension
de ce qui représente
la théologie réformée
ou les calvinismes
ils pensent
que la théologie réformée
met une emphase
unilatérale
dans la souveraineté
des dieux
dans les saluts
ce n'est pas le cas
la théologie réformée
elle est plutôt
entrant
de ne pas oser
devenir très
philosophique
ou arrogant
dans sa compréhension
de la Bible
je ne peux pas croire
seulement
aux vérités bibliques
où je peux tout
comprendre
ou tout expliquer
si
quelques vérités
sont présentées
de manière
très claire
explicite
dans la Bible
et qu'elles aient
l'apparence
des contradictions
ou qu'elles présentent
une impossibilité
des compréhensions
exhaustives
de ma part
de comment ces choses
peuvent marcher
de manière
un parallèle
un chrétien
va se dire
la Bible
est la parole
de Dieu
c'est clair
dans la Bible
je ne peux pas nier
je ne peux pas
déchirer
certains passages
d'écriture
donc Dieu
dans sa souveraineté
par sa grâce
nous rappelle
que
les saints esprits
va assurer
la persévérance
de tous les saints
qui c'est lui
qui opère
les vouloirs
et les fers
mais dans les mêmes
passages
où ça dit
qu'il opère
les vouloirs
et les fers
la Bible
nous exhorte
qu'il faut
développer
notre foi
avec rente
qu'il nous faut
s'aimer
pour l'esprit
et non pour la chair
que chacun
va raccolter
ce qu'il a s'aimé
et donc la Bible
nous enseigne
de manière très claire
que
Dieu agit
de manière souveraine
mais la manière
dont Dieu
agit
souverainement
ne supprime
ne supprime pas
ne nie pas
mais utilise
comme moyen
secondaire
pour accomplir
ce décret
la réalité
de la responsabilité
humaine
le Saint-Esprit
a opéré
la volonté
en nous
la nouvelle naissance
quel est
le vrai chrétien
qui ne peut pas
dire
que c'est
sa volonté
de se scientifier
c'est ma volonté
de me scientifier
quelqu'un
qui a nouveau
par contre
le Saint-Esprit
a celui
qui assure
que cette nouvelle
volonté a été
produite par lui-même
par Dieu-même
et qu'elle sera
maintenue
et renouvelée
par le Saint-Esprit
lui-même
et donc
la réalité
c'est que
les causes
secondaires
pour donner
une illustration
si Dieu
par exemple
a décrété
qu'une personne
allait prospérer
de manière juste
il a décrété
que quelqu'un
serait riche
par exemple
Dieu avait décrété
aussi
que cette personne
serait une personne
préoccupée
et diligente
à travailler
de manière honnête
à être diligent
à étudier
à passer
des bonnes formations
à s'efforcer
pour produire
les bonnes choses
si Dieu
a décrété
par exemple
ce qui j'allais
peut-être
faire tomber
mon portable
il a décrété
aussi
la loi
de la gravité
les causes
secondaires
elles existent
de manière réelle
la responsabilité
humaine
est réelle
et tout vrai
chrétien
sera responsable
et diligent
pour plus
qu'un chrétien
légitime
soit résistant
à croire
à ses vérités
il va se dire
donc si c'est comme ça
je vais rien faire
je vais pas lire
ma bible
tu vas voir
j'ai la capacité
de résister
si il est vraiment
chrétien
il n'arrivera
jamais à faire
ce qu'il est en train
de dire
qu'il peut faire
car le Saint-Esprit
a opéré
dans la volonté
le Saint-Esprit
a transformé
notre nouvelle nature
nous sommes ceux
qui voulons
nous sanctifier
nous sommes ceux
qui voulons
lire la bible
et pour plus
que la chair
parfois
prenne l'avance
nous savons
que celle-là
nous attriste
nous savons
que le Saint-Esprit
nous gêne
nous savons
que plus tôt
ou plus tard
nous allons reprendre
nos bonnes disciplines
et donc
la permanence
de Saint-Esprit
n'annule pas
les faits
que nous devons
cultiver
l'aspect cultivable
du fruit de l'Esprit
il est évident
dans plusieurs passages
par exemple
en Philippien
chapitre 2
verset 12
nous donc aussi
hébreu 12
puisque nous sommes
environnés
d'une si grande
nouée des témoins
rejetons tout
le fardeau
et les péchés
qui nous enveloppent
si facilement
et courons
avec persévérance
dans la carrière
qui nous est ouverte
à nous de courir
à nous d'aspirer
à nous de désirer
ayant les regards
fixés sur Jésus
donc ça c'est vraiment
la vision béatifique
pour tous les vrais
chrétiens
les chefs et consommateurs
de la foi
l'auteur
et les consommateurs
de la foi
vous êtes avec moi
c'est lui qui a commencé
c'est lui qui va finir
la foi
c'est lui les chefs
et les consommateurs
mais comment les textes
avaient commencé
puisque nous sommes environnés
d'une si grande
nouée des témoins
tous ces hommes des dieux
qui ont vécu une vie
très belle
au long de l'histoire
on est motivé
on doit suivre ses pas
on veut
courir la course
mais nous contemplons
les chefs
et les consommateurs
de la foi
qui ont vu de la joie
qui a été réservée
à souffrir
et mépriser
l'ignomie
et c'est assis
à la durée
de Dieu
et là verset 3
il dit
considérez en effet
celui qui a supporté
contre sa personne
une telle opposition
de la part des pécheurs
afin qu'il ne vous laissez
point l'âme découragée
vous n'avez pas encore
résisté jusqu'au sang
en luttant contre les péchés
qu'est-ce qui dit
attendez-nous
que nous résistions
jusqu'au sang
luttant contre les péchés
c'est une bataille réelle
mais l'assurance
qui nous encourage
l'assurance
de laquelle nous dépendons
pour progresser dans la foi
c'est de savoir
que Jésus
est l'auteur
et le consommateur
de notre foi
la même chose
Paul va révéler
chapitre 3
parce qu'il dira
à partir du verset 9
pour rire un peu du temps
Paul va dire
que son ambition
c'était de se retrouver
en Christ
de se trouver en Christ
au verset 9
pardon
non avec ma justice
celle qui vient de la loi
mais avec celle
qui s'obtient
par la foi
en Christ
donc c'est une justice
obtenue par la foi
mais ici
il n'est pas en train
de parler d'une justice
tout simplement
déclaratoire ou légale
une justice
qui devient
notre sanctification
la justice
qui vient des dieux
par la foi
afin de connaître Christ
et la puissance
de sa résurrection
et la communion
de ses souffrances
en dévenant
conforme à lui
dans sa mort
pour parvenir
si j'appuie
à la résurrection
donc il est en train
d'enclure
même les souffrances
qu'on traverse dans la vie
non comme une excuse
pour nous décourager
ou tomber dans un péché
mais comme un moyen
de nous retrouver
en participant
des souffrances du Christ
j'ai cassé récemment
maman
c'était rien
comparé à ce qui
Christ a souffert
mais en regardant
cette cicatrice
et les douleurs
que j'ai ressenties ici
ça m'a fait beaucoup penser
à la croix du calvaire
comprenez ?
ici Paul est en train
de parler des choses
beaucoup pires
qui est ça
mais comment lier
les difficultés
qu'on traverse
aux souffrances du Christ
et nous laisser
par l'esprit
être conduits
par nos épreuves
à ce qu'il peut
être en train de dire ici
malgré les difficultés
les détresses
je suis conduit
envers
les prix
donc remarquez ça bien
au verset 12
ce n'est pas
que j'ai déjà
importé les prix
ou que j'ai déjà
atteint la perfection
mais j'ai cours
pour tâcher
de les saisir
puisque moi aussi
j'étais saisi
par Jésus Christ
c'est quoi
la vraie vie chrétienne ?
langage
des jeux olympiques
d'une course
olympique
Paul très intéressé
au sport
et ici
il est en train
de comparer
sa vie spirituelle
à Christ
ce qui devrait
déterminer
la joie
de tous les chrétiens
pourquoi nous ne sommes
pas plus heureux ?
c'est car
on a perdu des vues
c'est qu'il y a
les prix pour nous
et on est en train
de se concentrer
sur les distractions
de cette course
donc
ce n'est pas
que j'ai déjà
importé les prix
ou que j'ai déjà
atteint la perfection
attention
mais j'ai cours
pour tâcher
de les saisir
puisque moi aussi
j'étais saisi
par Jésus Christ
qui est
le vrai chrétien
c'est lui
qui a été
saisi
par Jésus Christ
ce chapitre commence
avec Paul
qui parle
de tout son
curriculum
avant sa conversion
combien il avait
plein d'étoiles
dans sa vie
il était orgueilleux
il était l'un des principaux
dans sa tribu
dans son métier
et là il dit
lorsque Christ
est apparu
pour moi
toutes les étoiles
ont perdu
complètement leur bris
je les ai considérées
comme des labous
comparé à Christ
à la connaissance
de Christ
donc elle était
à partir de là
son ambition
suprême
qui est le vrai chrétien
c'est lui
qui a passé
par une telle
transformation
dans sa vie
et son cœur
sa vie
sa vision
son prix
était de connaître
davantage
les Christ
et s'est conformé
à lui
que ce soit
par les souffrances
ou pour n'importe
quelle circonstance
de vie
donc ici
il est en train
de dire
j'étais saisi
par les Christ
remarquez bien
quelles sont
les motivations
derrière
tous les renoncements
qu'un athlète
va faire dans sa vie
il ne va pas sortir
il ne va pas manger
beaucoup de choses
il va s'exercer
énormément
travailler
tous les jours
même pendant
les jours
il va être le mieux
pourquoi
car son ambition
dans l'âtre
est fixée
sur
un prix
sur un trophée
quel est notre trophée
en tant que chrétien
tous
on a été saisi
par cette sainte ambition
être retrouvé
en lui
porter les fruits
de l'esprit
manifester sa vie
en moi
vous comprenez
et donc là
comment nous comprenons
la souveraineté
des dieux
c'est dieux
dans sa grâce
souveraine
qui a révélé
les Christ
en nous
d'une telle manière
en notre conversion
qui est d'une fois
pour toutes
on a été marqué
par cette rencontre
et notre ambition
fondamentale
profonde
essentielle
c'est
être lié à Christ
lui plaire
être comme lui
qu'il soit manifesté en moi
voilà mon prix
c'est ça la réalité
de nous tous
quand on contemple
ce qui nous attend
la gloire
l'oeuvre du Saint-Esprit
c'est de nous conduire
à une progression
de sanctification
dans cette vie
et pour plus oscillante
qu'elle puisse être
dans nos vies
quand on arrivera
à la gloire
notre plus grande joie
son plus grand objectif
c'est de nous faire
comme les Christ
nous serons
comme lui
vous êtes avec moi
ça devrait être
notre ambition
c'est la seule
attention
entreprise
envers laquelle
nous avons
l'assurance
totale
des succès
tous les autres
projets de vos vies
vous n'auriez jamais
l'assurance
des réussites
totales
et c'est la chose
qui est la plus capable
de nous remplir
de nous satisfaire
et donc ici
nous voyons
de manière très claire
que nous courons
de manière responsable
diligente
c'est nous qui voulons
le faire
en même temps
on le fait
car on a été
saisi par Dieu
il y a plusieurs
d'autres passages
qui nous disent
la même chose
les passages
des Galates
devant laquelle
nous sommes
vous avez été
appelé à la liberté
et ensuite
donc rendez-vous
impératif
par la charité
servite les uns
des autres
marcher
selon l'esprit
donc beaucoup
d'impératifs
qui nous rappellent
pour plus
que les fruits
ne soient présentés
comme un fruit
c'est un fruit
que nous devons
chercher à produire
à manifester
coopérer
avec l'esprit
des dieux
et donc
les fruits
de l'esprit
sont cultivables
c'est de notre
responsabilité
de notre diligence
de l'accueillir
nous avons déjà
considéré
la semaine dernière
quelques aspects
ou quelques manières
de comment nous
pouvons accueillir
ou cultiver
les fruits
de l'esprit
et nous allons voir
quelques autres
aujourd'hui
on a vu
d'abord
que nous devons
développer
une soumission
consciente
aux impératifs
à accueillir
et cultiver
les influences
de l'esprit
pour produire
son fruit
et là
c'est juste
un rappel
de toutes ces
emphases
sur les impératifs
qu'on trouve
dans ces passages
et dans plusieurs
autres passages
si le saint-esprit
est l'esprit
des dieux
il est notre seigneur
il n'est pas
un otage
qui est là
pour sponsoriser
nos plaisirs
charnels
mettre le saint-esprit
contre le mur
manipuler
ses influences
ses puissances
penser que
car on dit aux personnes
de répéter
certaines paroles
ou phrases
le saint-esprit
sera obligé
à se manifester
ou déclarer
ou décréter
des choses
pour qu'il fasse
le saint-esprit
est le seigneur
et son intérêt
principal
n'est pas
de sponsoriser
notre idolâtrie
notre carnalité
son intérêt
principal
c'est de produire
son fruit en nous
et donc
à partir
du moment
que dans sa parole
nous voyons
des impératives
à nous
de nous soumettre
chercher
le saint-esprit
manifester
les fruits
vous voulez être
plutôt obéissant
ou continuer
à se victimiser
en disant
mais saint-esprit
la vie est tellement
difficile
j'ai tellement
des tâches
à accomplir
marcher
dans l'esprit
et vous
n'accomplirez
point les œuvres
de la chair
c'est là
la source
l'objectif
obéissance
ensuite
accueillir
et cultiver
les influences
du saint-esprit
immédiates
et médiées
donc là
on doit considérer
bien sûr
les influences
immédiates
du saint-esprit
il est libre
il est souverain
il est une personne
notre réaction
aux abus
et à la manière
dont
plusieurs mouvements
charismatiques
aujourd'hui
sont en train
de tordre
la priorité
de l'esprit
et la compréhension
de son ministère
ne doit pas
nous pousser
dans une direction
contraire
à point de supprimer
ses influences
sur nos vies
et donc
le saint-esprit
une personne
libre
souveraine
il agit
ça a été évoqué
pendant les offrandes
les grands réveils
qu'on a déjà traversé
et donc
nous pouvons traverser
des réveils
personnels
collectifs
c'est ce qu'on appelle
les bonnes saisons
donc le saint-esprit
il est là
en train d'agir
toujours
chez tous les chrétiens
mais il y a bien sûr
certaines saisons
dans la vie
où tout semble
être plus favorable
on sent
comme on était
plutôt soufflé
par l'évangile
de l'esprit
et d'être plus saint
de venir à l'église
de lire nos bibles
ça devient
beaucoup plus facile
d'être plus aimable
d'aimer plus les personnes
d'être plus fidèle
d'avoir plus de courage
pour partager l'évangile
tout devient plus facile
et pourquoi ?
car c'est comme si
l'été
explosait
au milieu de l'hiver
donc ça va
catalyser
maximiser
son opération
ordinaire
si on peut dire
comme ça
mais
il agit aussi
de manière immédiate
même au réveil
il est toujours
en train d'exercer
ses influences
chez tous les chrétiens
de manière interne
ok
on a parlé
en fait
de la manière
dont il nous
nous donne une envie
de prier
donc il illumine
un texte biblique
on avait médité
les matins
et il nous fait penser
à une personne
pour qui on doit prier
ou partager un conseil
etc
il est libre
et nous devons être
bien sûr très critérieux
à la manière
dont on va
interpréter ces choses
nous n'avons pas
l'inhérence apostolique
et nous ne devons jamais
dire aux personnes
voici ce qui dit l'éternel
sinon
on serait obligé
de prendre la Bible
et rajouter ce que vous dites
à la parole de Dieu
vous êtes en train
de réclamer
une autorité
une inspiration
que vous n'avez pas
dans le Nouveau Testament
dans la Nouvelle Alliance
ensuite
nous devons cultiver
aussi ces influences
par les moyens ordinaires
et là c'est la manière
la plus certaine
la plus objective
de nous rencontrer
avec les Saint-Esprit
dans les points de rencontre
qui lui-même
nous a établis
il nous a communiqués
donc si nous sommes
comme un arbre
planté près
d'un courant d'eau
on peut attendre parfois
que les Saint-Esprit
viennent avec ces pluies
glorieuses de réveil
et qu'ils pourvoient
ces réveils
sur nos vies
mais étant
les courants d'eau
lui-même
les Saint-Esprit
nous devons non seulement
attendre qu'ils viennent
descendre sur nous
mais nous devons aller aussi
à sa rencontre
et aller à sa rencontre
c'est ce qui devrait
dicter la vie ordinaire
de tout chrétien
et ce qu'on appelle
les points de rencontre
ce sont les moyens
des grâces
que le Saint-Esprit
nous a donné
donc notamment sa parole
la prière
les ordonnances
la communion des saints
donc tout ce qui
représente
les disciplines spirituelles
personnelles
ou communautaires
c'est là
et surtout là
que l'impératif
du Saint-Esprit
envers nous
se dirige
donc par exemple
lorsque la parole
des dieux
est prêchée
et le Saint-Esprit
fait osage
d'un prédicateur
pour laisser
non seulement
pour nourrir
toute la communauté
mais pour donner
l'impression
à certains d'entre nous
qu'il est
Dieu en train
de nous parler
directement
par exemple
c'est par
les conseils
par exemple
des pasteurs
des prédicateurs
que nous pouvons avoir
la perception
que nous sommes plutôt
en train de vouloir
nous conduire
par la perception
des situations
ou une décision
qu'on est en train
de nous laisser conduire
parfois par la chair
et lorsqu'on reçoit
un conseil
d'un membre de l'église
un frère
une soeur
et qu'il est
Saint-Esprit
confirme dans le cœur
en disant
tu sais très bien
que moi je suis en train
d'être poussé
dans cette direction
ça fait longtemps
et tu es en train
de résister
tu veux faire
ça dans ta chair
et Dieu va faire osage
de tous les membres
de l'église
la communion des saints
la multitude
des conseillers
pour confirmer
sa direction
dans nos vies
toujours biblique
nos moments
des prières
et personnelles
et communautaires
car nous n'avons
qu'est les nouveaux testaments
pour nous donner
les vrais paramètres
des chrétiens
nous ne pouvons pas
nous baser
sur la faiblesse
peut-être
des églises
de notre génération
pour nous dire
avec quelle fréquence
on devrait prier
ou quelle est l'importance
d'une réunion des prières
communautaire
on va vers la Bible
et la Bible nous montre
voici ce qu'il y a
un chrétien
une communauté
regardez avec quelle fréquence
ils se rassemblent
avec quelle fréquence
ils prient ensemble
regardez l'importance
et comment attendez-vous
mener une vie équilibrée
dans vos vies
manifester les fruits
de l'esprit
amour
joie
paix
patience
bonté
bénérité
si vous n'avez pas
à jour
les endroits
où le Saint-Esprit
a fixé
comme point de rencontre
pour cultiver
les fruits
en vous
et c'est intéressant
car
nous ne pouvons jamais
faire la distinction
la division
entre
les réveils
qui Dieu produit
et ce que le Saint-Esprit
produit en nous
de manière ordinaire
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
par là
on ne doit jamais
faire une distinction
entre la manière
dont le Saint-Esprit
travaille
par les moyens ordinaires
et ce qui travaille
quand il descend
par un réveil
c'est-à-dire
quelqu'un définit
les réveils
comme en étant
lorsque le Saint-Esprit
honore
de manière
extraordinaire
ses moyens ordinaires
donc bien sûr
qu'il y a eu
des moments
dans l'histoire
où le réveil
est arrivé
de manière soudaine
malgré
la condition spirituelle
ténébreuse
du peuple
mais c'est
très intéressant aussi
que l'engagement
et l'implication
envers les moyens
des grâces
dans la plupart des cas
ont été
les prémices
d'un réveil
c'est les premiers
travails du Saint-Esprit
faire que les personnes
soient plus intéressées
à la Bible
à l'église
plus assidues
qu'elles cherchent
avec plus des hâtes
la présence
du Saint-Esprit
qu'elles prient plus
pour la manifestation
du fruit de l'Esprit
et le réveil
devient
une espèce
des conséquences
dont les résultats
d'un réveil
c'est toujours
d'amplifier
davantage
la diligence
dans les moyens
des grâces
donc
la diligence
pour cultiver
la vie de l'Esprit
dans les moyens
des grâces
c'est aussi
une cause
qui est le résultat
de l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
c'est ce qui a conduit
Jonathan Edwards
à dire
que les manifestations
extérieures
d'une œuvre
légitime
du Saint-Esprit
peuvent nous tromper
on ne peut pas
établir
un motif
dans une église
qui est sous la
visitation du Saint-Esprit
en disant
à chaque fois
que le Saint-Esprit
vient
les personnes
doivent manifester
ses dons
ou à chaque fois
que le Saint-Esprit
vient
les personnes
doivent
agir
comme ceci
ou cela
crier
sauter des joies
etc
donc chacun
de nous
va réagir
tout comme
par exemple
quand on voit
une équipe
de foot
gagner un prix
une compétition
certains vont
tomber par terre
et pleurer
d'autres vont
sauter des joies
c'est clair
que lorsque
le Saint-Esprit
agit
on ne peut
jamais
rester apathique
mais la réalité
c'est qu'on devrait
être plus intéressé
par la manifestation
du fruit
de l'Esprit
qui est dans la manière
dont les personnes
puissent agir
ou réagir
de manière plus mature
moins mature
quand elles sont
sous l'impact
de la révélation
glorieuse du Christ
et de la manière
dont le Saint-Esprit
est en train d'agir
dans leur vie
le fait c'est que
c'est impossible
ceux qui réclament
l'œuvre du Saint-Esprit
de ne pas progresser
en amour
en patience
en joie
en paix
pour Christ surtout
pour leur semblable
pour les perdus
c'est impossible
qu'ils ne soient pas
plus engagés
et plus diligents
dans leur lecture biblique
dans leur prière
dans leur vie communautaire
etc
et donc
nous devrions
exercer
ou nous exercer
dans
les moyens des grâces
à nouveau
paroles
prières
églises
comme en étant
notre jardin
sacré
et de manière
très ordinaire
faire cet exercice
sacré
en attendant
!
et en désirant
et en cherchant
que le Saint-Esprit
puisse honorer
cet usage
de manière
glorieuse
et surnaturelle
!
on doit
chercher un réveil
car le réveil
à la fin des comptes
n'est qu'est
l'intensification
de l'œuvre
du Saint-Esprit
pour produire
les fruits
du Saint-Esprit
pour révéler
Christ en nous
et pour former
le Saint-Esprit
viendra
et vous fera
témoin
mes témoins
une autre définition
de réveil
très importante
c'est lorsque
Dieu
nous fortifie
pour témoigner
en nous traitant
de manière
très intime
en affirmant
son amour
paternel
Christ a dû
faire face
à la croix
à la montagne
de la Transfiguration
le ciel va s'ouvrir
et les pères
vont dire au fils
voici mon fils
bien-aimé
à lui
écouter
donc le ministère
au Saint-Esprit
c'est d'approfondir
la conviction
de l'amour
paternel
des dieux
en nous
afin qu'on ne puisse
pas s'empêcher
de manifester
notre filiation
divine
par les fruits
de l'Esprit
et la proclamation
de l'Évangile
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
de quelle manière
sacrée
les meilleures
générations
de chrétiens
ont toujours
protégé
les moyens
de grâce
récemment
en 2009
il y a eu
une recherche
qui a été faite
et qui faisait
une étude
elle a fait
avec
40 000 personnes
entre 8
et 80 ans
et c'était
un rapport
entre
la fréquence
des lectures
bibliques
pendant la semaine
et la transformation
des vies
des chrétiens
l'impact
de la lecture
biblique
c'est intéressant
car les personnes
qui pratiquaient
la lecture
biblique
jusqu'à 3 fois
par semaine
il n'y avait pas
beaucoup d'impact
presque aucun impact
très peu d'impact
dans leur vie
mais à partir
du moment
où ils lisaient
au moins 4 fois
par semaine
regardez bien
les changements
significatifs
les sentiments
des solitudes
étaient réduits
à 30%
prenez vos heures
de psychanalyse
et consacrez
à la lecture
biblique
et vous allez
voir les résultats
problèmes
des colères
diminués
des 32%
consommation
excessive
d'alcool
réduite
en 42%
relation amère
diminuée
des 40%
tendance
sexuelle
hors mariage
réduite
des 68%
sentiment
de stagnation
dans la vie spirituelle
diminuée
des 60%
vision
de la Bible
comme essentielle
à la vie
augmentée
des 60%
partage
de la foi
avec l'autrui
augmentée
1228%
disciplat
des autres
c'est votre responsabilité
de faire des disciples
c'est la responsabilité
des pasteurs
de vous équiper
c'est votre responsabilité
de faire des disciples
disciples
augmentés
de 1231%
mémorisation
des écritures
407%
quelles sont les leçons
les moyens ordinaires
des grâces
quelqu'un a déjà
définit
leau
jones lui-même
il disait
pendant tout son ministère
il aspirait
il cherchait un réveil
et car il a ciblé
très haut
par les moyens ordinaires
par la diligence
dans sa vie
des piétés
il a pu
ne pas vivre
un réveil
pour certains
il a vécu un réveil
car c'était
incroyable
sa prédication
et la manière
dont son église
a grandi
dans une génération
à Londres
très sceptique
mais pour plus
qu'il n'ait pas
considéré
qu'il avait
vécu un réveil
déjà son ministère
était extraordinaire
quelqu'un a dit
si on prend un verre
et qu'on essaye
de remplir
ces verres
dans une chute d'eau
quand on enlève
les verres
on a l'impression
que l'eau est rentrée
elle est sortie
mais elle n'est pas restée
et à plusieurs reprises
quand on est
dans cette diligence
de chercher
la présence
de son esprit
dans nos disciplines
régulières
parfois on a l'impression
que les sentiments
n'ont pas changé
il n'y a aucune chose
extraordinaire
qui s'est passée
mais c'est sûr
et certain
que les verres
soient plus purs
plus nettoyés
vous comprenez ?
et donc c'est très important
de considérer
quand on pense
par exemple
à la vie
des puritans
la discipline
ils faisaient leur travail
pour la gloire de Dieu
mais tous les jours
de la semaine
les matins
ils priaient avec leur famille
tous les jours
de la semaine
après les dîners
ils avaient un petit culte
familial
qui ne pouvaient pas
trop se prolonger
généralement
il y avait un jour
au milieu de la semaine
où les cultes
étaient un peu plus
ordonnés
les cultes familiales
les samedis
quand ils arrivaient
proches du soir
ils commençaient
à se préparer
pour les dimanches
pour réfléchir
dans la prédication
les chants
qui s'errent chantés
pour préparer l'âme
afin de maximiser
ce qu'ils allaient vivre
les dimanches
c'était les jours
de leur festin
ils s'élevaient tôt
avec leurs enfants
préparaient leurs enfants
pour les cultes
ensuite il y avait
les mondes communes
entre l'église
frères et sœurs
discussion spirituelle
il y avait les cultes
du soir
et après les cultes
catéchisme
avec les enfants
et révision
du serment
un membre
comment ?
c'était pas
qui est les puritains
en pasteur
c'est travailleurs
qui travaillaient
parfois dur
dans les champs
qui avaient une vie
difficile
avec des horaires
lourds
eux qui
dans plusieurs cas
habitaient
dans une seule chambre
avec toutes leurs
familles
et leurs enfants
et qui ne laissaient
pas d'avoir
plusieurs enfants
à cause
de la difficulté
de la vie
voici les modèles
qui nous avons
ce sont les modèles
bibliques
des mieux moments
de l'histoire
de l'église
je vous ai déjà présenté
comment Luther
il disait
les jours où je vois
que j'ai plein de choses
à faire
je me lève plutôt
pour prier davantage
on peut attester
comment
en considérant
les œuvres
de la chair
on a fait des séries
ici
et c'est glorieux
car j'ai eu pas mal
de retours des personnes
en disant à chaque fois
comment leur vie
a été améliorée
dans une ère
ou autre
gloire à Dieu
donc là
on atteste
que les moyens
des grâces
Dieu utilise
même par la prédication
pour les changements
des vies
le problème
c'est quand
on a mis en place
dans nos vies
quelques priorités
nécessaires
on a organisé
notre emploi
du temps
pour nous battre
contre certains péchés
et cela
a pris le temps
pour les disciplines
spirituelles
les points des rencontres
que Dieu a fixé
pour nous
si on n'a pas
la capacité
d'avoir du zèle
pour les bien-être
personnels
on a l'impression
qu'il faut qu'on ait
notre temps personnel
notre temps privé
notre temps de repos
pour pouvoir
mieux agir
comme chrétien
dans la société
j'aimerais
qu'ils vous montraient
dans la Bible
cette réalité
dans la vie
des chrétiens
qui ont les plus
manifesté
la vie du Christ
les fruits de l'esprit
car
ils n'ont pas été forgés
que par les bonnes saisons
que par la vie paisible
quand on se dit
j'ai besoin
de me reposer
au lieu d'aller
dans la réunion de prière
je ne trouve plus
le temps
de prier
ou lire la Bible
avec mes enfants
on a raté
l'emploi des temps
que Dieu a fixé
pour nous
on va prioriser
et préserver
de manière sacrée
la diligence
dans les moyens de grâce
et vous allez
gagner du temps
et je vous dirais même
gagner de la santé
préserver
votre argent même
et là
ça m'étonne
mais
malheureusement
ça fait partie
de notre génération
et c'est probable
que ça fasse partie
de la vie des chrétiens
aussi
ce qui ne devrait pas
être le cas
consommation
des psychotropes
exagération
dans les divertissements
addiction
d'internet
pas forcément
immoralité
distraction
idolâtrie
pour nous amuser
jusqu'à la mort
en pensant
que nous avons
besoin de ces choses
pour soulager
la difficulté
de la vie
dans les mondes
vous auriez
de l'affliction
Dieu n'a jamais
promis en pyjama
après la conversion
c'est une armure
et la promesse
et la certitude
c'est
les plus
on respecte
de manière sacrée
l'usage
des moyens
des grâces
les plus
l'ensemble
de la vie
on pense
que c'est
cette vie
organisée
au plus d'argent
aux meilleures conditions
de vie
qui nous donnerait
plus de capacité
d'agir avec amour
joie
paix
patience
bonté
bénignité
fidélité
douceur
et tempérance
mais ce que la Bible
insiste pour nous dire
c'est
lisez
votre Bible
tous les jours
priez
le maximum
qui vous poussiez
développez
votre amour
et votre amitié
votre service
mutuel
rendez-vous
par la charité
serviteurs
les uns des autres
portez vos fardeaux
soyez assidus
dans les temples
à l'église
et il ne vous manquera
aucune minute
de votre vie
car si vous cherchez
d'abord et avant tout
les rangs des cieux
et sa justice
toutes les autres
cieuses
seront rajoutées
par des cieux
!
nous ne pouvons pas douter
de cet impératif
divin
ce n'est même pas
une promesse
c'est un impératif
la promesse
est assurée
donc
si vous avez été bénis
par cette prédication
je vous prie de remercier
à Loïc
car dans notre réunion
pastorale
il nous a rappelé
en fait
qu'on devrait plutôt
nous plonger plus
sur la considération
des moyens des grâces
ce n'est pas quelque chose
qu'on soit toujours conscient
les termes moyens des grâces
qu'est-ce que ça va signifier
les moyens des grâces
ce sont les moyens
que le Saint-Esprit
a déterminé
qu'il opérerait
sa grâce
en nous
et nous ne pouvons
jamais exagérer
par rapport
à l'importance
d'être diligent
dans ses moyens sacrés
le Saint-Esprit
peut apporter
un réveil
et comme il est souverain
il peut ne pas
apporter un réveil
la certitude
c'est que
si nous sommes
à notre poste
nous n'allons pas
satisfaire
les désirs de la chair
plusieurs chrétiens
semblent être
dans l'infirmiérie
d'un hôpital de guerre
toujours en train
de se battre
contre les passions
de la chair
la meilleure manière
de résister à la chair
n'est pas forcément
de nous battre
directement contre elle
la meilleure manière
de résister à la chair
n'est pas en faisant
des séries de prédications
contre l'immoralité sexuelle
ou la pornographie
la meilleure manière
de résister à la chair
c'est de cultiver
positivement
les fruits de l'esprit
Amen
soyons diligents
et responsables
pour que l'esprit
travaille plus simplement
dans nos vies
levons-nous pour prier
Amen